flames
smoking flames on the side of my head
burning
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we close out another season with
neil patrick harris he's an emmy
award-winning actor who for decades has
entertained audiences on everything from
acclaimed sitcoms to broadway stages
subscribe to his wondercade newsletter
for weekly odds and ends from the mind
of mph and finally he also stars in a
brand new comedy series on netflix it's
called uncoupled and it's streaming now
neil patrick harris welcome to the show
it's my great pleasure i know that
you're a product of new mexico how are
you around spicy food i know that you're
partial to hatch chilis partial to hatch
green chilies love a good red sauce
enchiladas jalapenos nachos is my jam
uh not not so much like go for this hot
sauce on top of eggs kind of person
i like a good wing so yeah i'm excited
i'm nervous
you ready to get started i also have a
weak digestive system oh right right so
i'm not worried about this part i'm
worried about
like two hours from now yeah yeah when
i'm [ __ ] liquid
that's club
am i supposed to have just a single bite
or go for the whole thing what's your
plan so i kind of ride with wherever the
guest takes that's interesting i
mirrored it it's like the improv game
mm-hmm
where if i do things like this then
you're gonna match me all the way
through you grab a milk and grab water
i'm on it i'm honestly glad i wore a
white suit for this
[Music]
so in the new netflix series uncoupled
you play the role of a new york city
real estate agent who's agonizing his
way through a heartbreak after being
dumped unceremoniously by his partner of
17 years how do you think about blending
comedy and tragedy because even though
the show has very painful themes i found
it to be a comfort watching
experience the tonal element was the
trickiest part for me like it was the
thing i was worried about most but it's
a darren star show so it's got
a definite sex in the city emily and
paris kind of vibe to it
but a breakup show seems fairly
relatable and fairly universal my
character in it gets dumped and he
thinks everything's fine it's not like
they're in a bad relationship and then
it ends so it's really rug pulled out
from underneath you and so i think the
tonal shifts of
draw of comedy and then all of a sudden
something dramatic happens is kind of
how life works and also makes the drama
makes the emotion play hit harder
in many ways right because you're not
expecting it
hmm
mmm that's good
i've got some
pineapple vibe
a tropical vibe it's actually out of
hawaii
nice yeah
mahalo mahalo
so you performed magic for iconic late
night hosts including johnny carson
craig ferguson and david letterman yum
who would you say is the most criminally
underrated magician of all time because
it's interesting to me that harry
houdini is a household name but then
howard thurston isn't
hmm
yeah that's a good quality of all time
there's a guy named
baltier de culta who created all kinds
of illusions and a lot of the
david copperfields and the big
illusionists use these principles of
table bases and black art and stuff and
i just thought dakota was super cool he
had one a trick called the decolta chair
and they still do it i think they still
do it in the phantom of the opera
on the big broad way where the person
sits in a chair and covers themselves
with a cloth and then you
whip the cloth off you can see the form
of the person underneath and when you
whip the cloth off the they're gone
and it's a whole like gimmicked
situation bob's
and um
i always thought that was super
that's cool okay from oaxaca
i've been to oaxaca
oh well maybe this will take you back
it does
okay that's good and spicy yeah this
one's a step up for sure
but
it's okay it's like a mole spice yeah
yeah exactly
it doesn't feel like a
[Music]
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] spice you know like a
joke like right well we've got some dorm
room pranks we've got some dorm room
pranks here assuming that's on its way
hmm the magical is good there we go
i've heard you describe yourself as a
technical actor in a recent new york
times profile a craftsman not a
psychologist maybe this is morbid but
how would you break down the mechanics
of dying on camera like for that death
scene and gone girl that was
intentionally broken down
by david fincher for me for that very
reason because
it
it was something that you can't really
rehearse too much
because
we would film everything right up into
right up to the
wet work as he called it and so we did
all that but then once it happened he
really wanted to make sure it felt real
and you don't really know you can't
really pull from resources about
what it what you'd look like when your
throat was slit right
david imagined that with a sharp knife
getting your throat slit would you
wouldn't feel any pain
so he want he he would make me
make me
show him what it would look like
because it was also mid-orgasm
it was i'm about to i'm a uh
and then it was this very
gruesome
intentionally gruesome feeling of
calm of like
confusion of
what's why is everything warm
and then oh why is it red and then what
then you start blacking out because all
of the blood that's going to your brain
is now going out your neck
so yeah it was it was super technical
fun fact did you know that you're the
second ever oscars host to die in a film
that was nominated at the ceremony that
you were hosting
who was the first
robert shaw
jaws wow
i wouldn't think robert shaw would be
thought of as like the funniest
choice for an oscar host
that's an interesting call yeah but
carrying on the legacy he had a great
death he had a great death you had a
great death oh thanks and the oscars
talk it's a lovely segue to the next
wing are you ready to move on
death segway okay here we go
this is los calientes verde here in the
four spot okay
i learned you're supposed to take one of
these out and just suck on the other one
but now i'm worried about take small
bites yeah speaking of mechanics
you got good wing eating mechanics
yum
okay i can see why now that's like a
lingering
warm meat yeah sometimes they build
sometimes they have a little time delay
to them and then a little bit of a
cumulative effect here now that we're on
four
oh that's true yeah it's all now sitting
coming the walls are closing in over
here you're getting warm it's getting
warm
so between secret numbers with hugh
jackman raps written on the fly with
lin-manuel miranda what would you say is
the closest you've ever flown to the sun
while hosting an award show
oh man
we had done the tony awards at a smaller
theater and then we got to go back to
radio city and so that was the perfect
structural conceit for an opening number
let's make the biggest number we can
possibly come up with we'll call it
bigger
and we'll just have
as many people from as many shows will
kitchen sink it
and so
we got lin-manuel miranda
and tom kitt to write this number called
bigger
start small and it just expanded and
expanded and so many things could have
gone really wrong and did at the dress
rehearsal that morning did when we were
doing the like the tech rehearsal the
day before did when we got all the casts
together and for some reason
it all just went impeccably well
it's like fun to watch again it still
gives me like goosebumps it was one of
the great six minutes of my life
what's one thing that the fancy pants
prime time emmys could learn from the
people who put together spike tvs 2010
video game awards
well the video they did a weird thing
with this video game awards that i did
let me know it was the first year they
had tried to do like augmented reality
so that the audience at home was seeing
something different than what the
audience there was seeing
meaning that there'd be this big wide
open stage and it would look like this
stage like
collapsed or appeared or turned into
boxes and stuff
so at home it looked great
in the live audience that was sitting
there they had to act like you know
things were happening when nothing was
happening which i thought i felt bad for
all of the people who were nominated
because there was a very boring show for
them
seventh reaper the seventh reaper
that's more about like a texas
smokehouse kind of yeah very smoky
like like beans like beans in a can like
beans over a fireplace you know
yeah and i think like three it's kind of
another noticeable step up from the
other ones
like just like my hands shake a little
bit yeah
it'll be uh it'll be a party over here
by the end of this wow
yeah man it gets warmer and warmer the
longer you wait that's the show i
thought so that when you swallowed it
would be done no no yeah that would just
shake clean like an etch-a-sketch that
doesn't happen it doesn't i think
there's a lot it gets a little bit worse
actually
okay
is it true that paul varehovan would
chase you guys around with brooms and
scream i'm a [ __ ] bug through a
megaphone while shooting the battle
scenes for starship troopers
100 true
and paul was such a cool director but he
he knew what his strengths were
and he knew and and he if he didn't have
a strength in it he would absolve
himself from it so he didn't know like
the cg stuff there was a guy named phil
tippett who was really famous who did
all of the bugs and the cg it was one of
the first big cg bug movies now there's
a lot of them and so yeah he would just
say look up there look in the corner
right ah it's the bugs the bugs
i wasn't in most of those scenes because
i just came marching in at the end of
the battles yeah and said carry on
everything's fine here
um
paul also didn't know
comedy he didn't care about comedy at
all because i remember asking him
like paul is it funnier if i say
it this way or if i say it this way he
said
i don't know american comedy
just say whatever you think is funniest
thanks director
are you ready to move on here to the
back half
if i had a nickel yes
[Laughter]
hot and saucy hot and saucy collards and
ghosts okay
this one is a different color
yeah than the others we're getting into
like a darker
peppery situation
so i've heard you say something that i
really relate to which is respect for
audience has been the north star
throughout your career how did you see
that philosophy playing out doing a long
running celebrated sitcom like how i met
your mother
too often content plays
down to the
to the people who are observing it the
very people that you're having watch
you're sort of treating them as if
you need to like keep focusing them and
maybe you do but i just don't i don't
like when i'm watching a show
and they say
coming up
and then they start to show like
rupaul's drag race love the show and
then i'm i'm watching the show
coming up and they start showing i'm
like no stop it i'm about i'm watching
the show you're showing me about to show
me the best part i'm not going anywhere
i'm watching the show so i think you
have to respect the audience as much as
possible how i met your mother did it
carter and craig are our creators
valued the storytelling conceit of
flashing forward i think appreciating
inside jokes trusting that an audience
that's watching season five will still
pick up a bit that was a callback from
season two those kind of things
my lips are stinging yeah
so this next one is tier fiends curse
that doesn't sound good that doesn't
sound promising with you 100 i agree
with you a hundred percent
tearfing i like that it's spelled t-y-r
and not t-e-a-r although we'll find out
soon this is yellowish in color
has anyone vomited
[Music]
wow
that's spicy
it's really tasty yeah i could that
sounds just about to say like it's hot
but you're you're enjoying it this is
kind of the jalapeno
wow that's really hot
but it's like the jalapeno hot which i
laugh at sometimes because i'll get eat
real hot jalapeno and then i'll just
want to have like another bite of
jalapeno yeah some addictive thing with
wow that's so hot though yeah but i like
when i end up in that sort of culinary
space where it's like really spicy but
so delicious yeah that becomes this
labor of love you know this dance that
i'm having with my meal
wow
okay so now do you have something like
this in your refrigerator right now
this spicy when i'm off the clock when
i'm off the clock i'm a lot a lot of
juice a lot of salads a lot of cereal
you know but you won't pump
you won't compliment
your eggs with something super crazy hot
right not when i'm off the clock not one
yeah no
no they got to bring the cameras
so i really enjoyed your appearance on
the woodworking talk show with steve
ramsey what so far has been the crowning
achievement the crowning design
achievement of your garage workshop so
i literally just did the first steve
ramsey weekend woodworker project
called the bmw oh hell yeah the basic
mobile workstation
made out of one sheet of plywood two two
by fours and one one by four
and i i was so emasculated by the
experience it was so traumatizing and
challenging and i appreciate woodworkers
on a whole different level because i you
know you have to work through it
everything was like a little off and
wobbly it was so frustrating but i did
it i finished it and i'm actually quite
proud of it
i talked so long there just to kind of
calm my
cords down
well not long enough because it gave me
just that little lull to jump in
so this is to bomb beyond insanity
there's a particular corner i should
grab there's no place to hide okay okay
oh no i don't want to all right
wow
it tastes like poison
yeah
i don't want to swallow it
i keep chewing hoping that it'll go away
there's nowhere to hide
wow
wow yeah that's that's freaky freakishly
hot freakishly hot
flames
smoking flames on the side of my head
burning
it's from clue the movie
but you are very composed i have to say
that i have to say that very composed
though thanks under the circumstances
i'm also this way when i'm drunk
you know you can get people will tell me
that i'm a decent drunk like i'll say
wow i drank too much last night people
say really you didn't seem like you were
that messed up
oh wow yeah
yeah so your weekly newslet so your
weekly newsletter wondercade is a mix of
negroni hacks and culinary musings and
pearls of wisdom
what made you want to filter your
hobbies through a newsletter rather than
say a tick tock account like every other
celebrity that's a perfect uh question
and i have an actual legit answer for it
i
i like old i like tactile old-timey
things i like
finding
a recipe in an actual drawer of a of a
shop that you know like an antique store
like that's the recipe i want to try you
like typewriters i love typewriters
i really do i know you do um
and so the notion that if you sign up
every wednesday you'll get a newsletter
read it at your leisure but it's not
something that you have to watch on like
an instagram feed you don't have to
watch quickly
i am almost crying while i'm that up i
am tearing up like i actually have tears
coming out of my eyes right now
and then wondercade is a real workout of
the mind as much as it is a midweek
diversion
what remains hot while it's frozen and
tastes like doom and then when you cut
the wrong wire the place goes boom
the bomb
hey
i see what you did there
i was thinking that's a riddle and i'm
about to die inside
and i put those two things together
the bomb is no joke should we try it
again
if you want to go let's see let's see
what because now i'm wondering if
my mouth is kind of ready for it yeah i
love this
now that you know what to expect right
now that it was awful mm-hmm is it gonna
be
better than next time well
am i already predisposed to it
no it's [ __ ] really hot no it sucks
just as bad as it did the first time
the same receptors that were making me
cry are now mad at me that i've made
that dumb choice to eat it again
wow
why did i do that
i don't know and why did i listen to you
you should have stopped me
you're the host of the show
[Music]
wow are you ready to the big bite that
come through
yeah oh you like basically clean this
wing
season 18 finale
we're going out with a bang
this next one
is the dingo psycho sauce
that was my nickname in prison
[Music]
dingo psychosis
[Music]
this is a 15
out of 10.
yep
and sucks just the same just
but at least it feels like a meal like i
feel it yeah i feel it's kind of like a
spicy curry it has kind of a spicy curry
vibe to it sorry vibe right some
redeeming culinary qualities with this
one none in the other one
that's just making me sweat though there
we go maybe we got second to bomb
wow
what to you distinguishes a great escape
room from a mediocre one
puzzles that
aren't just
um
placed into the room for no reason
so if puzzles that are there's they're
supported by the narrative
everything in the room should make sense
like you don't want to be doing a
sherlock holmes escape room and then you
have to suddenly do a sudoku puzzle
and it doesn't make much sense you know
so as long as they all like and i like a
good uh
secret like a trapdoor
so a lot of times escape rooms will seem
like it's one room and then when you
finally put the fourth gem into the
thing like cooking something open
there's a second room and you get to
like crawl through a little tunnel
tunnels are fun too oh
man
now it burns
so consistently yeah and it doesn't feel
to me now that we've done this and it's
ever going to stop
so my body is just kind of getting used
to time yeah we're forever changed
all right neil
okay
oh you're shaking it
you don't have to if you don't want to
oh well when you put it like that
[Music]
no i'm in a pass
okay
last dab
oh hey this has hot ones yeah yeah this
is your own yeah we make this one
but you know what if you don't like it
just like you didn't like this one yeah
let us know
let us know
i'm having like
when you're inhaling and exhaling
through your mouth right now yes
so that yeah you know i'm from chicago
so sometimes during the winter i feel
like the cold weather has a taste to it
and then this is like the antithesis of
that
okay
okay so this already has this on there
yeah
and now i'm adding more
did you add like a whole bunch i just
you know i probably over did it a little
bit that's right matt you know okay
season 18 finale let's do this baby
cheers
[Music]
it's really hot no no no but the good
news is neil patrick harris this marks
the end of our bizarro world lunch and
puts a cherry on the top of season 18
and to close things out
no you're the product of such wonderment
such imagination and to really put a bow
on season 18
i present to you a magic kit and you
would be so humbled if you would put a
bow on season 18 with an impromptu neil
patrick paris magic trick we got a
standard deck of cards in there and then
a whole bunch of fun stuff
yeah watch this
[Music]
i'll use my heat wrap
[Music]
oh
wow
here
neil patrick harris
standing ovation in the studio and look
at you taking on the wings of death and
living to tell the tale now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life
because we just talk about things i'm
doing yeah like we have a show coming
out or anything like that watch uh
uncoupled
on netflix cabin jamal half hour
episodes and you get to see my naked
butt
that's all i
[Applause]
oh
got
that's that one's experience
nice that was fun
wow
yeah and now what do you do milk yeah
you just survive but
15 20 minutes you'll be good to go
and they'll never be able to take this
one away from you
you did it
well played man that was funny
hey what's going on hot ones fans we
brought the heat to the freezer aisle
with our hot ones boneless chicken bites
and used smash sales records and all of
our wildest expectations so what did we
do we made more that's right we are in
with five new flavors of hot ones
boneless chicken bites and five new ways
for you to bring hot ones home from the
classic to the classic garlic fresno
edition to the los calientes trio of
flavor verde rojo barbacoa
visit hot ones challenge dot com for
more information and to find a store
near you hot ones boneless chicken bites
you're in the hot seat now